this piles upon piles of rubbish here on
Paris streets this is part of a more
than two-week protest by bin collectors
angry at president macron's
controversial pension reform now burning
rubbish has become a symbol of
protesters anger against their president
for pushing through those pension
reforms without a vote in Parliament and
just streets away from where we are now
marches are protesting through the
capital saying that they have been
ignored by their president and all of
this just a few days before the expected
arrival of King Charles we already know
that some of the Personnel involved in
rolling out the red carpet or refusing
to do so and it's likely that the Pomp
and ceremony that he was supposed to be
greeted with may be scaled back